we will conclude today's ceremony later
by singing the alma mater but before
that I would like to give you my charge
it's a great pleasure to be here with
you for my first commencement once again
on behalf of all of us sitting on the
stage then we congratulate all the
graduates and your families on your
wonderful achievement this is my
freshman year at CMU and as a freshman I
get to speak at the commencement not bad
I said what a country
the first thing I did upon arriving here
was to launch a year-long listening tour
listening to students faculty alumni
trustees and staff to get to know
Carnegie Mellon many of you graduating
today many of you students who are
leaving the campus today played a very
important role in my listening tour I
thank you for your help I heard so many
powerful ideas from you and from all
across the CMU community thank you I'm
pleased to report that we could convert
a number of your ideas into action
during the first year during my first
year you strongly suggested a new
campus-wide seed grant funding program
to allow us to move forward to nurture
the creative entrepreneurial spirit of
the CMU community your idea led to the
launch of proceed a program we announced
a few months ago this year you very
kindly organized a series of symposia
for my inauguration here entitled
crossing boundaries and transforming
lives on some major research and
education challenges of our time and you
brought leading experts from around the
world to campus to talk about these
topics thank you we secured the
foundational gifts to develop a major
new gateway to our campus The Temper
quad this year David Tepper provided the
largest gift ever in the history of the
university by a CMU alumnus thank you
David
this new project will catalyze our
activity in entrepreneurship and
innovation across the university and
create a new home for the business
school we also announced the Simon
initiative involving faculty from every
college in school on the campus to build
on CMU's global leadership in learning
science to deliver effective learning
outcomes 2014 is as you know the
hundredth anniversary of our renowned
School of Drama we celebrated this
landmark in Pittsburgh in new york city
and in hollywood just two weeks ago we
establish a new partnership with the
Tony Awards the first for a university
to recognize outstanding and inspiring
theatre educators in American K through
12 schools and of course CMU itself has
produced so many wonderful mentors who
have changed the landscape of
entertainment at theater we also have
created innovative new partnerships with
major IT companies such as IBM and Yahoo
and just last week directly in response
to many comments I received from my
listening tour especially from many of
the graduating students we announced a
major university wide priority to create
a large number of presidential
scholarships for undergraduate students
and presidential fellowship for graduate
student students we launched this
important initiative with an initial
endowment pool of 30 million dollars
specifically raised for this purpose
thank you for suggesting this and thank
you to all the benefactors for helping
us to launch this very important
activity
so it's been a very busy and productive
year for all of us I'm most grateful to
all who have contributed to make all of
this happen you are privileged to have
amazing choices before you I will
confidently predict one thing the pace
of change will accelerate and bring
incredible new capabilities for us
graduates in your lifetime information
and communication technologies have
opened doors in so many new directions
they have allowed hundreds of millions
of people around the world to move out
of poverty and seize new opportunities
across the entire spectrum of human
action and thought as new ideas take
hold in one sphere they have an impact
that ripples across many other domains
for example it was advances in computer
science that made possible the mapping
of the human genome which in turn has
generated new tools for medical
diagnosis and treatment and has opened
new intellectual domains in personalized
medicine and big data big data analytics
and machine learning are already
changing how we learn how we work what
we buy how we travel and how we govern
ourselves I wish to briefly discuss two
topics for the new graduates as you
leave this campus the first topic deals
with a perspective with which you
approach major challenges whether they
are your challenges or global challenges
the second deals with leadership the US
National Academy of Engineering a select
group of top leaders in engineering from
America in 1999 published a list of 20
greatest engineering achievements of the
20th century you could probably guess
what was on that list you can go to
their website and see it electrification
commercial aviation the invention of the
radio
television and the Internet the
development of fossil fuels and in turn
the invention of the automobile and the
creation of the major highway networks
improvements in agricultural
productivity and the rise of nuclear
energy these have been enormously
beneficial to humankind and their
adoption happen very quickly with many
of them are rising in the lifetime of
your parents and your grandparents the
US National Academy of Engineering in
2005 issued another list this time the
list of the 14 greatest challenges
facing humanity in the 21st century here
are a few of them develop carbon
sequestration methods restore and
improve urban infrastructure engineer
better medicines prevent nuclear terror
secure cyberspace when you compare these
two lists side-by-side it is striking
how many of the 21st century challenges
directly spring from the unintended
consequences of the 20th century
achievements it is because of the rice
rice in the petroleum-based world
economy that we must address the
consequences of the build-up of carbon
in the atmosphere including pollution
and carbon sequestration the spread of
the internet connectivity that began in
the late 20th century has brought
countless benefits to our lives and
careers from banking to entertainment to
of course shutterfly but through this
technology we also face problems of
securing cyberspace protecting our
privacy preventing media piracy and
countering cyber terrorism some might
say that this is nothing unique to our
time in the late Middle Ages innovative
designs for faster ships created Richard
trading connections around the
Mediterranean and beyond but those
faster ships also eventually brought
with them the bubonic plague that
devastated major cities in Central
asia and europe so unintended
consequences are not new but what is
view today is the speed with which such
consequences occur the global air travel
system that makes it possible for us to
jet around the world also allows
infectious diseases bacteria viruses and
parasites to fly right along with us so
how are we going to solve the grand
challenges of the 21st century some of
which may be a direct consequence of the
20 greatest engineering achievements of
the 20th century if we as scholars
creative minds engineers and scientists
were so smart in the last century in
creating so many innovations that change
the world how much smarter are we likely
to be just within a few decades as a
human race that we will have the wisdom
to solve all the unintended consequences
we created along the way as we were to
solve new challenges what new unintended
consequences will arise and how do we
know them there is no simple answer to
this my own interpretation is that it is
not just enough to look at grand
challenges as engineering challenges
technological challenges or scientific
challenges they are also human
challenges most of these unintended
consequences facing the world have their
roots in the human condition here is an
example the National Science Foundation
which I headed until last year has long
funded imported research to develop
sophisticated tools to provide early
warnings for serious weather events as
tornadoes and hurricanes this work has
led to very useful tools and
technologies that improve our
predictions but every year despite
getting much better forecasts dozens of
people still die in tornadoes and
hurricanes I learned that such tragic
tragedies often occur not because of our
inability to accurately predict bad
weather events
but because of our inability to predict
how would be how people would react to
warnings about bad weather events human
behavior as much as technology is
important here in 1850 a few years after
the legendary inventor Michael Faraday
first produced electricity in his lab in
London the then chancellor of the
exchequer or the Treasury Secretary of
England William Gladstone was among the
many skeptics who could not imagine how
electricity could be anything more than
a parlor trick by a scientist who is
using taxpayer money to satisfy his
curiosity so me mr. Gladstone said mr.
Faraday what is the value of your new
invention of electricity why should we
support your scientific curiosity this
is what Gladstone asked mr. Faraday
responded sir one day you will tax it
and and tax they did we are still paying
heavy taxes for energy and electricity
around the world Faraday's witty answer
to Gladstone points to one important
lesson about technologies we are often
not good at predicting the full range of
their effects especially when as is all
too common short-term priorities narrow
focus override long-term analysis if we
approach major problems with an
expansive human-centered framework we
can collectively create an inclusive
society that will find a way for human
contributions to be made with dignity
strength and beauty so what does it take
it requires seriously combining
perspectives from science and
engineering on the one hand with
contributions of artists designers
architects social scientists humanists
are those trained in economics business
and policy working together we must
continue to build new approaches
designed with careful attention to the
needs and capacities of the human beings
who will use them who will abuse them
and who will be changed by them studies
also suggest that the fields of
entertainment music and the arts
appropriately combined with the latest
in technology can improve learning
outcomes in areas as diverse as learning
languages sciences and engineering and
this is where CMU excels I think first
of all this requires us to collaborate
on teams that include many disciplines
partnership of the sort that has long
flourished at a place like Carnegie
Mellon University this is why I firmly
believe that CMU's unique strengths in
crossing boundaries will position us to
be global leaders in addressing many of
the grand challenges that the National
Academy of Engineering talked about more
so than any other university at CMU you
be well prepared here to take this our
approach to your future work wherever
you may work and of course you have just
officially joined the worldwide network
or nine of 97,000 Carnegie Mellon alumni
who will connect with you in making this
happen who will work with you this
brings me to my second and final point
leadership here I want to reiterate a
few things that I said to student
leaders just a couple of days ago Peter
Drucker the thoughtful observer of
organizations once said management is
doing things right leadership is doing
the right things at CMU your experiences
have helped you to focus on the right
things and also helped you learn how to
do them the right way take this to the
world with a broader perspective to
address the Grand Challenges go outside
your comfort zone someone once said
leaders take their people where they
want to go great leaders take their
people where they ought to go even if
they initially do not want to go there
as you become leaders in whatever you
choose to do be prepared to step outside
your comfort zone not recklessly but
taking calculated risks this has been
said by others before good judgment
comes from experience but often
experience comes from bad judgment as
serious as the problems facing this
planet are on this day looking at you I
cannot help but be optimistic deeply
optimistic about the future and I look
forward with high hopes for what all of
you graduates will accomplish in the
many years to come I know that you are
prepared enough creative enough and
powerful enough to take on anything
congratulations again and thank you for
giving me this opportunity to share my
freshman year with you I
I shall always remember you the class of
2014 as my first CMU graduating class
thank you